whoever's here we need to know if this
is working you got ten minutes with us
five minutes either that or the getaway
driver goes away Mike working thanks
hello
doesn't seem to be going up can you guys
hear us I'm his oldest Tyrone 56 years
old as of today 56 and going strong I'm
only gonna beer for 10 minutes all right
we got 76 people in this chat thank you
to everyone who's saying that stuff so
it seems to be if you guys can hear us
can you confirmed is our first time
doing a live stream on this isn't it
yeah 56 I know right it looked great
another thing too as a birthday present
me no sarcasm I'm gonna do today
no sarcasm whatsoever wow there's so
many comments coming in here somebody
sent a bunch of french fries dad listen
guys I'm only here for ten minutes so
let's do a speed round of questions
right now you can speed around in
questions cuz I got I got some personal
life stuff to tend to in a little bit
yeah like being born thank you guys for
all the happy birthday switches first
question that comes in answering it have
you seen met apocalypse Metalocalypse
that's how he says it
no I have not seen it BAM aren't you
happy ask that question could really
break that one down this Joel guy says
he [ __ ] himself gaming channel when
have you ever been to London actually we
were supposed to for the none I'm sure
you've seen some youtubers out there we
were supposed to be part of that but I'm
a track again but we instead opted for
Mexico because you much rather go to
Mexico than London that was our choice
wasn't Warner Brothers has we love you
Warner Brothers hashtag nipple chill
gang all halfway nipple chill gang no I
mean that's a new t-shirt at their
nipple chill game gosh you know what I'm
gonna pay attention to how many people
just keep leaving the chat dude def
digit games like this guy don't care
about it [ __ ] yeah what was being born
like I actually was a person who
had the umbilical cord around his neck
so that was by choice and my mom had to
have a c-section so she could you know
keep me alive so they could go in and
attached a GoPro but then your mom gave
birth to the nor I with the GoPro on so
there's footage of that somewhere [ __ ]
this guy Ringo says [ __ ] this guy but
thanks for the view count buddy that's
what I gotta say what's Tom Bateman
what's up Tommy so what's up
where'd you work well part of the park
you work in I'll try and find the
comments vesting night take care buddy
yeah where are you kids we're in Los
Angeles you guys should come pay us a
visit
oh all loving the gun Shambo she watches
a patreon
he got Falls of some patron guys I want
to say to youse ain't a sponsored thing
or anything like that but we've been
posting a lot on Stardust just for our
own shits and giggles go follow us there
galactic grapes masturbated a bunch of
times already you guys are the best
reactors out there
wrong very wrong how long on tase the
best Magnus's I am six I firstly love
diversity
I personally love actually you know
there's quite a few reaction channels
that I could really recommend to you
guys that you know like there's cinema
siblings crazy couple LM reactions Shay
Shay's one of my faves
Shay's one of my waves sweet Tyrone is a
legend I was actually on the phone with
Tyrone yesterday Oh Joanie what's up my
wife I just responded to one of your
comments look at all these happy
birthday comments this is the only
reason I'm here just to read this happy
birthday big dick says Tom Cruise all he
knows Tom Cruise
small guy with a big penis guys we got
six minutes left for I for us sound off
sound off in the comments
did you see Tyrone's rage video because
you cannon by a spider-man ps4 Pro even
better
I talked with Tyrone on the phone about
that about the ps4 oh yeah it wasn't
whatever you guys are talking about he's
just getting anything he's gonna
livestream
simple stuff right here you can let us
borrow it and we can play all those new
game yeah we do live in LA it's really
uh it's really awesome yes if you drive
around la long enough you're bound to
fall down to find this because you grew
up in LA we see celebrities left and
right it's not superstitions some days I
go out and the only people I see or
celebrities all day the only reason I'm
doing the live stream is because there's
this thing called YouTube algorithm and
if we don't keep my if we don't keep
putting up videos YouTube is just like
screw you guys we are slaves so here you
guys goes the live chat of nothing
it's exactly like GTA 5 out here
galactic grapes the tire owner and I
plan on doing another collab next time
we're in the same state we're definitely
doing in its however I have this weird
relationship where every like three to
six months to randomly get on a phone
call for like 45 minutes and catch up I
prefer Michael Myers but I think there
are probably more enjoyable Jason movies
this fit this live stream will not be
demonetized
I'll make sure of it that's why I'm
gonna avoid to say words like con [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] that balls on a steering
wheel a fat balls I'm sorry I was the
worst kill the strippers what pawnshop
first two dollars Han shot that's the
most we've made on a YouTube video in a
long time thank you dude do you see the
nun movie we did do to him barrio we
cannot talk about it but we can't say a
positive thing we were some good scores
and it wasn't movie we could there was
some good scares in it yummy sounds is
gorgeous good Jenna Randolph requested
Kings from the Golden Circle what's up
you see it's higher Harry talkin to me
are you talking to gentlemen which one
are you talking to
aggravation director is the oxy well we
already went through this vamp man he's
just gonna leave again Lord and Miller
my pick by the way if there was someone
to take over guardians I'm saying Lord
and Miller Lord Miller backup John
Francis Daley Greg saying the time I
harab you know but come on my birthday
livestream tell me what to do sorry I'll
tie it up for the both of us
[ __ ] you man have you congratulating
your mother yet I want to be the most
offensive YouTube
so in a rush it's going on buddy dude do
you have to do that you're already a
patron James it's okay you don't have to
ask you two for a refund
take that to Buddy Miller Haitian mega
thank you so my field back as I do got a
little bit like three minutes so keep
the livestream going and I will make
tips on your behalf
oh wow it's really kinda who wins in
Godzilla versus King Kong oh it's gonna
be like Logan Palmer's ksi [ __ ] sure
ah yeah twenty bucks
wait a minute oh yeah yeah yeah thank
you
and shout-out to my friend Jack maja
Jack maja hey Acme huh I get it now
masturbation a guy well if the videos
gonna be do you monetize might as well
talk about jacking off alright do you
remember Jenna Randolph who requested
the King Circle trailer if you don't and
you're yes I do
Jenna's Jenna's very very attractive
human being I think yes Devore he's sick
this is all I want to do I just want to
shout out anyone who who I pretty gotta
there's a super chest thank you were
people sometimes contribute or any guy I
didn't know that we should play live
stream yeah don't don't don't try to do
any editing anymore [ __ ] let
subscribers [ __ ] guys thank you so much
this is really cool
looks like I'm putting all my birthday
money but Jon appreciate that guys next
my way of factoring it out you could
have half my Birds even the ones outside
of this livestream you you on half of my
presidency thanks
where do you guys gonna do it all
reactors collaboration YouTube movie
maybe a kind of a dull movie don't you
think if we're all just reacting and
stuff
mommy me you're the one said he says
Greg is a coward I say thanks for
contributing to the engagement of this
live stream my friend any batter that's
a weirdo my mine my nipple shows are
through the roof right now they're ready
to slice this t-shirt
I want you to know that you're hot as
well that's what happens hole created
guys seriously it's all these people who
have been like who who is this guy night
Joseph hounds Thank You Joseph for being
you your money's worth more than our
curse pal you you are just one of the
sexiest people I've ever seen timbre
larsa's best reactions on YouTube oh
thanks man a vase we'll keep an eye out
for you on there but I'm telling you
guys I appreciate that it's it's still
it's blasphemous HD and jeans hey some
of your nose comments just got reverted
to a different reactor Jason Takes
Manhattan probably a better movie but
Jason X has that [ __ ] yeah nitrogen
kill Greg did she ask her I got you
[ __ ] tonight I'm definitely
masturbating oh yeah he's gonna
masturbate on my face Scuba Steve thanks
man dude school listen if anyone's
already a patron here you just make me
feel guilty contributing here in the
superjet I just started feeling bad
Thank You scuba guys follow scuba
Steve's Instagram he's got a great
Instagram Miguel Sweden's thanks thanks
dude
loving McHale dude James bonds and
alright franchise that's a stable one
Jase you're gonna have a thank [ __ ]
maybe I am bi and kind of have a crush
on Greg you know it's funny I kind of
have a crush on Greg and I'm not bi so
isn't that ironic dude well for you
that's like complex but not like you
know like emotionally bye you're just
physically but I've snuck a lot of dicks
you know what I'm saying
that's a way to be that's a perfectly
acceptable way to be get your dick I
love that common I'm not emotionally gay
I can't react oh by the way people have
been asking me if you go to my Instagram
I gave my whole thoughts on Eminem's new
album I [ __ ] loved it
love that all album I've been Ringo its
but a long time since I've [ __ ] got a
[ __ ] out of [ __ ] sometime forty six
seven don't talk smack about my movies
this October Michael will whooped Wow is
there like a this is like a fan base of
horror movie people thanks for your
contribution or call it'll say like it
is you're paying money thanks for you
or eating to our awkwardly is that like
thing where people get like [ __ ]
competitive and you know you know what
like the way that we compose I know that
among the horror fans people debate
their slashers and [ __ ] DC does not suck
it's awesome my new or what made you or
what make great action really I don't
know about that make reactions great and
reactions great again reaction
complicated I want to see Marlon Brando
was alive so we could see him and Donald
Trump talk with each other alright guys
listen I know that this comment boxes
were getting so into the you know the
craziness of you know [ __ ] Marvel and
[ __ ] DC as I'd expect on a YouTube
livestream thing to not go happy you
guys are here thank you to all who so
kindly gave some birthday presents thank
you again Maurice is a really sweetie
you think course or he's you do you
think you do your thing love Jason lives
thank you for all the happy birthday
wishes I did want to come on here really
quick and want to end this with saying
to you guys that you know like at the
beginning of I don't know was at this
time last like around this time last
year's when John know you moved in here
exactly a year ago and we've changed a
lot of the operation since for you guys
who are loyal fans you know that we like
edit our videos a lot more and you know
we try to make our discussions actually
really worthwhile and we since you moved
in we've also done is more like random
sketches that are sometimes behind
reactions and everything so it's been
one hell of a journey early part of last
year was really rough lately the
channels been doing great averaging
about five million views a month still
on the channel still getting about like
five to ten thousand subscribers a month
so thank you guys for sticking with us
YouTube was a little bit rough for a
while but really do mean it when I say I
love all the support that you guys have
been giving so thank you so much and I
had to whoa I'm trying to leave man you
can't just pay a hundred bucks right
I'm trying to joke Romo checking shot
disappears listen ask John for a dick
pic you'll send it to you right away
thank you so much it's very kind of you
dick pics for all that's paid hi
unfortunately you have plans and I got
to get going but Roma check that's
that's incredibly generous of you so
thank you buddy really do appreciate
that seriously much love to all of you
man thank you so much for wishing me
happy birthday thank you caster all the
wonderful birthday money thank you that
I was I forgot there was a super chat
thing on the livestream thank you clip
pick y'all send you my foot all right
buzz well let you go you have a great
rest of your day maybe homes if I'm a
little drunk --all I'll hop on for a
dream tonight if your eyes peeled much
loved you guys and thank you seriously
to everyone who gave all that birthday
money thank you that does not go
unrecognized and oh yeah yeah thanks
buddy
hello sir I gotta go but thank thank you
so much secular Gabriel did I have to
hit the end button now happening now bye
love you guys